[Music]
so there we go NDC London rap for
another year pretty good wasn't it so
this year we're gonna get a Minnesota
isn't that right Todd yeah I'm so
excited to bring the NBC community to my
home state of Minnesota we have like an
amazing tech community of like DevOps
and Big Data people and I'm so excited
to bring all of the things that NDC is
gonna offer like my friend weigh me what
are you gonna talk about
I'm super excited with the NDC in
Minnesota so I'll be doing a 2-day
workshop on blockchain programming and
how to deploy my contracts on to the ETM
network so I'm looking forward today
about you Duncan I'm gonna be talking
about angular and how to build
Enterprise angular applications and how
to manage state with n JX & NX
workspaces I can't wait mark how about
you couple of talks in the conference
dotnet core native build executables
things and cloud native dotnet core
things two completely different talks
both with native in the title so yeah
that's gonna be awesome battle sounds
pretty awesome I can't wait
NDC in the US of A
[Music]